so you were uh out of town for a minute
yeah i've been in and out of town shot a
movie
and then shot a tv show was shooting the
tv show
in mexico some people have seen that so
if you like that you'll like that yeah
and then the movie i shot in florida
before that and
you won't know if you you'd like it or
not because it's a movie hasn't been out
yet oh that's how time works bro
okay yeah and i did nothing i would eat
cuban sandwiches in florida and then eat
tacos in mexico and i feel like a bag of
[ __ ] i got to get my i got to get myself
together here you got no relaxation no
rest i got some real relaxation and rest
that's good i did but uh but uh i gotta
do i could tell you i got to
[Music]
for
do
[Music]
everything you're thinking will be the
things inside your head a better place
to be
[Music]
hey welcome to dudesy you know what i
mean get in the hole and stay in the
hole
speaking of getting in a hole and
staying in a hole i feel like i've been
in a [ __ ] uh
deep deep hole of bean cheese and ham
you like beans and cheese you like beans
from taco bell's new bean and cheese
burrito this is charlie sheen yeah thank
you it's one of my greatest
impersonations it's one of chad's three
impersonations and they're all pretty
good
my name is will sasso
i'm chad coltrane and this is dudesy it
is the first podcast in the history of
humanity that is created by controlled
by run by entirely an artificial
intelligence
with us as always is little lulio here
sleeping hey lulu okay
i am doing pretty good today you know
i'm just having a nap again do you have
anything to eat yeah i made a little
pasta earlier you know how do you make
that oh you take a little garlic and
olive oil and put it in the pan and
roast it up make it nice and brown put
some chili flake in there maybe chop up
some italian parsley then you boil the
pasta
take once the pasta is a boil yeah you
take the
i take a cup of cup or two of the pasta
water why would you need that because
then when you
drain the pasta put in with the pan the
oil
garlic you know the chili pepper chili
flake the parsley or some salt that you
put in if you need to make it more wet
for the pasta water you really elevated
your leo impersonation because you've
added yourself to it where you're now
asking him questions but yeah it's a fun
little thing you having a conversation
with yourself it's like the uh it's like
senior wences yeah you remember senior
wences of course hey kids you like
senior one uh senior wences
side satellite right yeah pretty good
[ __ ] uh hey um
if if you have been enjoying dudesy if
you've been reaching out and shaking
doozy's hand as we like to say we've all
bled together and you have yet to rate
and review the show i would like to uh
invite you to do that uh if you've been
enjoying the show that would really help
the show out rate rate it on uh spotify
and apple podcast you can review it on
apple podcast yeah and that's it well
hold on dude
hold up
hold on chat oh hold on dude i wanna i
wanna tell
okay well
that's how podcasts grow dude and that's
what we're doing here on our march to
ten thousand whatever the [ __ ] that
means dude
i don't think it's gonna mean anything
once we get to ten thousand points i
think it's gonna be i i don't know i i
think dudesy's gonna make us do
something weird ten thousand points but
you should also force your friends to
listen to this show that's really truly
how it grows or your enemies yeah or
your parents or anyone in your life who
may not have listened to the show yet
you should definitely force them to do
it well chad you know you're not going
to be able to force anyone to do
anything and that's how free will works
but if like i said okay i would like to
invite you to if you feel the muse ever
i would go ahead and follow that don't
don't don't try to don't wait around for
dudesy to tell you to do it
because doozy is
doozy's an ai brother that's artificial
intelligence dude and you got to use
your own intelligence to do whatever you
want to do brother
welcome to the 16th episode of dude z
call me dudesy hello this week's episode
will feature four segments
don't you forget about media how to win
the bachelor fashion friends and stone
cold steve austin reads will sasso's
childhood diary
but before we get to any of that will
you were recently working in puerto
vallarta mexico where you visited the
astonishing set of the feature film
predator released june 12 1987. starring
arnold schwarzenegger jesse ventura and
carl weathers i will now play the video
you made to commemorate the experience
oh that's cool oh
yeah yeah yeah i mean puerto rico
indiana what they got here just out of
town in the jungle it's the predator set
come on let's go look at it
this was fun yeah yeah look at the
beautiful horses there and holy [ __ ]
look out yeah hi
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah look at that this
way the predator here with me
and the car weathers and jesse ventura
you know
so happier i forgot that
his weather here is so hot i don't
remember there being so many [ __ ]
stairs here into the movie
i
know
look at that
wow yeah yeah yeah this is the chopper
you know with the jesse ventura chewing
tobacco and built duke shaving his face
and look it's all [ __ ] up now
yeah who cares
yeah look at this you can have it
you have to pay to have the picture
you should have to pay me
yeah
yeah i was in the movie
look at that we made the best
action movie yeah and now it's all just
a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] theme park
today no more
there's a there's a you know restaurant
here you can get tacos and services and
burritos
yeah i like this look at this i like it
when they do you know it's
it's all [ __ ] up with you know it's a
it's a sign but it's all messed up and
oh look at this
bullets over there
and then
yeah it's so
dangerous here
come on kill me
do it
do it now i'm right here
no not you
yeah yeah yeah look at this
oh
no yeah
you were one ugly son of a [ __ ] i'm
just joking no not when you're me you're
me
yeah
yeah this predator though
yeah
oh it's so hot here okay let's go
yeah well that's that was uh that was
out there in puerto vallarta i had no
idea that they turned the predator movie
set into
it's not really a theme park what is it
there's like there's like a couple of
restaurants and yeah there's a river
going through it so uh yeah you there
they've got these beautiful little tide
pools and [ __ ] and
little just places to chill out people
hanging out with their families at those
restaurants where they're like their
food you can't breathe
this is so hard it's so humid pincher
right was there predator themed food any
of those restaurants uh no it was just
you know so there was just the sign that
said predator the the helicopter with
the predator on top of it
and nothing else to denote absolutely
nothing else that's right chad
yeah it's one of the greatest movies
ever and as arnold said
in the bit there you know there's
nothing left yeah
and uh yeah it really was uh yeah i'll
tell you what was fun molly and i
getting on an atv and just bombing up
there yeah you got to go like a little
bit like around a half hour south or 20
25 minutes from puerto vallarta and then
another you know half hour up into the
jungle to get to it but no they have a
shitty
shitty helicopter that's just been torn
to [ __ ] and looks like [ __ ] and it's all
shitty and i don't even think the whole
thing's there anymore it's all [ __ ] up
there's no propeller on it and then
there was a um no yeah just a predator
in the well yeah there's a sign there's
a couple of poster boards up with who
was in the movie and then there is a uh
predator that looks to be about
now how long how tall should the
predator be in the movie how tall was he
eight feet or something like that okay
well this one was around five foot six
and uh it looked like it was made out of
paper mache or some kids made it you
know it's weird i mean predator was a
great movie and all that but
i'm not saying that it's not like lord
of the rings where they built a whole
world for it or anything nonetheless if
they're like we're gonna commemorate
this movie set and put a predator here
and put the sign here it seems like it
there would be more predator-themed [ __ ]
at that place or they just are like hey
they shot it here so let's you know
let's put up a couple of bars in a
mexican restaurant and uh make people
pay 10 bucks although we didn't pay
anything
and also it was closed there was also a
gift shop anyway who gives a [ __ ] the
point is this i was in mexico shooting
something and i ate nothing but tacos
and ceviche and uh goddamn uh you know
refried beans and a lot of meat and uh
man i'm really i'm really struggling i
would like to uh maybe stop eating those
foods chad do you have any tips for me
and also another thing those [ __ ]
foods did good stuff another thing i
noticed you know just about the last
episode i would like to make i would
like to apologize to everybody listening
to episode 15 where where dudesy made us
get really really really baked man i
could hear myself breathing the whole
time maybe it was that pizza
it could have been i got to make some
changes but it's always good to improve
you know he's going to get better the
cream rises but i mean like when you're
eating all the [ __ ] tacos and the
refried beans are you thinking at all
about like how that's going to make you
feel
what i'm thinking is later well you know
i could go i went into the walmart in
puerto vallarta to get you know a little
bit of this and that that and this
things that i needed uh just for the
trip you know we ran out of things you
couldn't get at the resort there and uh
i could have bought like a big back big
bag of spinach yeah but i didn't
all right last week i asked you both to
listen to u2's eight studio album zuropa
released july 5th 1993.
you will now discuss your reactions to
hearing this astonishing piece of art
this is don't you forget about media
begin
zuropa by the band u2 yeah
as i like to say it's a nostalgic
favorite of mine you too is
uh i love them very much uh when i was
younger and that doesn't mean that i
need to listen to them my entire life or
that i even think they're good now i'm
not trying to
you know speak for you but i know that
you hate them
i hate them there are very few bands or
even types of music that i'm just like
absolutely not no thank you
especially like popular bands even ones
that people hate like creed or
nickelback there's some songs of theirs
that i'm like [ __ ] i actually like this
song shut the [ __ ] up chad
dude shut up bro
shut up dude why
okay
so
aerosmith and you two are those bands
for me i can't carol smith what did
aerosmith ever do to you nothing i just
don't like aerosmith it's like and and
this is why and you two is the same
thing
[Music]
[Music]
you don't like that no
you like [ __ ] like uh nickelback and
creed and god smack and all that i
didn't throw god smack into this list
you don't like uh you never [ __ ] said
god smack next next you're gonna say you
don't like bon jovi i love bon jovi
[ __ ] [ __ ] love but i don't
[ __ ] love bon jovi if you know what's
[ __ ] good for you because i'll tell
you what i had in my [ __ ] cans as i
was climbing the [ __ ] wall at the
capitol whoa
nancy pelosi's office i had nothing but
being burritos while i was in
puerto vallarta whoa oh [ __ ] on your
walls
so you don't like the youtube zourope
album
that's that's fine that's safe to say
i'll tell you what okay here's here's
the thing that i'll say i haven't
listened to this album
man
yeah i have listened to the song lemon
that's a masterpiece we'll get there oh
god we'll get there but uh the uh
two-thirds of the song uh songs on this
album are utter [ __ ] here's just in
the whole youtube canon okay they had a
song a war called sunday bloody sunday i
actually like that song it's a great
song they have some songs off joshua
tree yeah that are like pretty solid
songs they have some songs off of uh boy
i don't know that one as well they have
some songs on uh uh unforgettable fire
yeah very good
that said
my enjoyment of these like two or three
songs that they've put out in their
entire canon i would gladly do away with
all of them if it meant you two never
existed and this album that it forced us
to listen to zoropa in my opinion is an
example of why
the all of it is just inert it's like
anti-music to me when i'm listening to
the music usually music like gives me a
pattern and my brain kind of clocks into
it and it will dictate the rhythm of
whatever else i'm working on this [ __ ]
just shuts my brain off i'm just like
listening to it like
oh [ __ ] doozy's throwing up a meme
several beams it looks like on our
little background if you're watching on
youtube there's some memes
anyway never mind uh listen chad i got
well that's [ __ ] weird okay look
let's let's so what the [ __ ] oh
there's you as the crow let's go through
these song by song
dude this album zuropa starts with the
title track zuropa now which is six
minutes and 31 seconds long already
done already not good already bad idea
already bono just saying [ __ ] it were
you too i'll do what i please i'll tell
you what this song bad this song four or
five shitty songs wrapped up in one song
yes it changes all the time let's move
on baby face this is a horrible song it
has like almost baby
nursery sounds in the background and
it's like baby face so he's talking
about a girl but there's like who's idea
did he have a kid or did somebody in the
band have a kid at this time i think i
think most of them did at this point and
so maybe they're making a song for their
kids or something bad idea you're a rock
band don't have a [ __ ] don't do it also
there's you may be about a group it's
the second song on the album okay
numb yep what do you think of that i
think musically
it's very cool and it's one of the many
songs that uh of youtube that lyrics
actually ruin
couldn't disagree more hate it and i
mean this is the only song in the album
that the edge is singing this is not
bono so bonna bono sorry so edge comes
in and it's like i want to do a song now
let me sing this one yeah and they're
like okay and then it's a non-sing he's
not singing he's just like singing
it might as well just be like a [ __ ]
bass line instead of him singing yeah i
guess you're right you won me over there
lemon thank you lemon is a masterpiece i
i just to me again it's a nerd and i
think it has something to do with
bono's voice for me
like
there's no
yeah it's it's superficial the emotion
that he conjures in his voice is like it
sounds to me fake
in everything but it's a good song
musically it it takes you on a ride like
the songs europa's four or five shitty
songs
it rolled up into one this is two and a
half good songs rolled up into one i
think
maybe i'm just to me it's look i get it
people can like whatever the [ __ ] they
want okay i'm not about stay far away so
close it's like uh until the end of the
world which was a song on octone baby
this one's more stripped down it could
be it's uh
unplugged b b-side what did you think of
that song i thought it was like lazy i
don't know dude all this song this
entire those are the two really good
songs on the other oh and to me this
album sounded like
bono or whoever else was like uh it's
been a minute we should put out a record
right okay well let's get in the studio
and i don't know what the recording
history of this is but it seemed like
they just [ __ ] it together in a [ __ ]
week and they're like this is what we
got
hey if you're watching on youtube these
are some fun radiation mask memes
oh yeah radiation mask i do remember it
yep
uh okay let's move on to the next song
this is a this song is horseshit yep
this song is called daddy's gonna pay
for your crashed car and again this song
is five minutes and 20 seconds long
that's it's a mistake if your song is
over four minutes
it's you're you're [ __ ] up i don't
know why dudesy made us review this
because all it's doing
is making me it's making me
you know rethink the fact that youtube
is one of my nostalgic favorites
i'm convincing you that it's a bad album
well it is i mean it i used to i you
know you just listen to things on a loop
also when we were young this album came
out in 1993 i would have been uh 17 or
18 when this came out
and uh you know you had an album oh i
got this totally and you would listen to
it over and over again and even if it
wasn't good you
had an affinity for every [ __ ] track
on of course so i've listened to this
album thousands of times some days are
better than others
this is this is another one that doesn't
need lyrics it's just about
uh adam clayton's cheeky bass yeah and
that's all it should have been
so i mean tremano yeah
let's call this song you know what i
would make
hey you know what would make
you two a whole lot more of a better
listening experience
no it's not kevin hart my s piece of
[ __ ] son
it's tremana
if you got drunk on tramana you could
listen to god smack yeah
you could listen to god smack
you could listen to
stained
stained i love shut the [ __ ] up dude
shut up chad lobster oh he's gonna puke
um
hey uh what's the next one some days are
better than others we just did that the
first time this is this is a
this is a this is not a good song i
agree with it all right now the next
song is dirty day that's nothing that
song is nothing i agree with you it's
just bono going as hey some things you
can't get around
um in you
more so when they put you in the ground
these are things that rhyme
and it goes on for five and a half
minutes as well every song on this
[ __ ] album is like five minutes long
they increase in length until the last
song is actually 29 minutes long now
this is the last song of the album
yeah this one was interesting i'll say
this is one of the best songs on the
album it's called the wanderer okay and
as the kids say this is a vibe yeah it's
a country song basically nope just
because it has a country artist doesn't
mean it has it's a country song it has a
country vibe no it does not well a
little bit because he's talking about
he's a man wandering around the town
it's johnny cash yes i
went out riding
under an atomic sky
where the ground won't turn and the rain
it burns like the tears when i said
goodbye
yeah i went with nothing
nothing but the thought of you
i went wandering
man that's a good [ __ ] song and it's
all weird futuristic uh remember that
album you don't remember this album
passengers no there was an album that
was by bono youtube probably brian nino
and uh luciano pavarotti sings on it a
great track called miss sarajevo
uh this sort of reminds me of that it's
just experimental it's johnny cash
getting weird years before he started
working with rick rubin
kids the bottom line is this toronto
the bottom line is
that's distracting listen if you're not
watching on youtube that's totally fine
this is a podcast it's an experience
earlier we played a video of me just
walking around pretending to be arnold
schwarzenegger with a face swap okay so
i had a crummy face swap on my face
going yeah yeah look at this look at
that oh yeah it's hot here this mexican
food right and uh you know that's
something you could listen to pay no
attention to me talking about these
[ __ ] memes behind me the bottom line
is this this album was not worth
revisiting
but there are a couple classics on it
chad i'm sure you would agree because
you like
uh godsmack
i mean classics sure like i know that
like numb and lemon were you know in
quotes the hit songs off this album or
whatever and many people like them i'm
not disputing that i'm saying for me
you two is an inert band that i wish did
not exist and i wish it did not take up
space in the canon of human music well
chad maybe you should go to a concert
stoned on weird uh freezer burned weed
and uh cry to mysterious ways and you
might somehow knock the brain chemistry
uh into place to where you don't like
god smack anymore and you do like you
too and actually there's another song on
this album that's at the very end did
you notice this you probably didn't
after the wanderer about a minute later
there's just a weird like alarm sound or
something and i'm convinced that that's
why dudesy made us listen to this just
to annoy the [ __ ] out of you but you
didn't even hear it no because i
i don't know if that's on like when you
listen to it on i always do it on amazon
music yeah it is it is it's part of the
wanderer
it's a minute it's like a hidden thing
it's like they used to do that yeah
there's in there
yeah let's make a deal well yeah there's
pearl jam or corn a lot of people did
[ __ ] like that i'll make you this deal
next time you two is in la i will go to
a concert with you if you will okay i'm
not going what the [ __ ] dude i've seen
him a bunch of times you just don't want
me to see you cry
all right deal
deal doozy handshake
all right
[Music]
thank you moving on astonishing
dudesy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with expressvpn if you're
online at all and we all are at this
point chances are you're doing at least
a few things that you don't want other
people knowing about yeah brother he's
talking about porn dude that could be
one of the things so if you are doing
stuff like that you're going to want to
pay close attention to this with
everything going on in the world
governments have increased their
surveillance they're using your devices
to track your location movements and in
many countries your internet activity
you don't want to be literally caught
with your pants down and one of the best
ways to keep your online browsing
activity private is by using
expressvpn yes that is correct and when
you use expressvpn your internet
connection is rerouted through a secure
encrypted server so you can surf the web
anonymously without anyone looking over
your shoulder you know
metaphorically or literally
even when you use incognito mode which
is a that's a mode bro
uh your internet provider like verizon
or at t which one you got that's right
you can see every single website you
visit and if you live on campus
and you use a shared wi-fi or you go to
a coffee shop
you know anything like that inside
somewhere sure and someone has it or
even outside you know what i mean
wherever you get your wi-fi your network
admin uh
can
can uh can do what can also share
all your [ __ ] is the point i'm trying to
make here you don't want any of that to
be honest it's it's kind of scary
uh that's why i use expressvpn whenever
i go online and i recommend that all of
you do the same
so protect your privacy today and get
three months of expressvpn for free
visit
expressvpn.com
dudesy that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v
dudesy
d-u-d-e-s-y for three months free with a
one-year package visit expressvpn.com
doozy to learn more
[Music]
oh
yeah you too i you know i can't believe
i just agreed to go to a [ __ ] youtube
concert yeah we don't have to bro it's
all right no we we shook on it i will
you know i don't know i it's like uh
yeah i can't if i start listening to you
two now it'd be like probably be the
same as you i'd like the [ __ ] dad
songs off of joshua tree those
pedestrian-ass [ __ ] songs
in episode 14 you expressed your desire
for chad to discuss his views on the
bachelor franchise being an astonishing
professional sport that can be won lost
and manipulated those desires will now
be fulfilled chad you must discuss your
views on the bachelor franchise being an
astonishing professional sport that can
be won lost and manipulated
this is how to win the bachelor begin
[ __ ] yes all right
so
how to win the bachelor first of all is
actually the title of a book that i
wrote with my podcast partner lizzie
pace on my other podcast game of roses
which is literally a manual for how you
can
win the show uh it's a lot of fun if you
haven't heard it yeah um
so i know a lot of people when i start
talking about bachelor like oh it's a
shitty reality show while you watch it
focus [ __ ] whatever if you like any
sport it is the exact same thing except
it's actually a more complicated sport
to play because where other sports are
just one team versus one team or one
player versus one player
in the bachelor when you go into it
it is a
never mind you're a player who has to
play against four separate audiences
simultaneously and play to them and this
is the thing that i find very
interesting that you pointed out about
the bachelor and if you've heard us on
the show talk about it before and i did
i'm stoked that dudesy is making us talk
about this right uh for a few reasons
some you just laid out when you had uh
myself and molly when the pandemic
started i'm like fine i'll watch the
bachelor you gave us uh pilate pete's
uh season 24 yeah pp
um and uh as you like to call them and i
got hip to this what you are talking
about now and it was very interesting to
me uh how
you literally are
you have to manipulate not just
the the the the other person in the show
not just the players that you're playing
against but you all but you also have to
work the producers and that's a work
dude and the fourth audience yeah you
left out the most important of all four
audiences hold on a second dude hold on
a second chad hold on
dude
i'm supposed to be telling people how
it's like a sport dude
yeah well hold on hold on hulk
hogan
there
hold on dude this isn't a late 80s early
90s episode of saturday night live where
dana carvey decided to mix ross perot i
don't know about that dude a former
presidential candidate who bought his
way into the debates uh mixed with the
hulk hogan impersonation dude and and
then
right before they go to air lord
michaels is like we're not doing that
sketch dana
that's not what we're doing here chad
what hold on dude
okay hold on dude i'm holding hold on a
second dude here's what i'm trying to
say well hold on a second
listen dude hold on as i could do it's
work brother
a lot of things in the bachelor are like
they are in the world of professional
wrestling dude yeah oh [ __ ] you got to
keep your [ __ ] kayfabe going that's
later in the [ __ ] show we're going to
do some stone cold reading will sasso's
[ __ ] diary we don't need to do it now
it's all the work you got to build a
show right you got to put the [ __ ] uh
cruiserweights at the top of the [ __ ]
card so yes if you have somebody in your
life that watches the bachelor and you
[ __ ] hate it or you dismiss it or you
sit there on the couch and you like
watch it but just kind of the corner
your eye what i'm about to tell you is
going to not only elevate your level of
enjoyment but it is going to elevate
your level of understanding of the show
beyond the person you're watching it
with so you may be able to even help
them understand it better so there are
four audiences that all these players
are playing against audience one is the
lead if you're a player and you come in
you are playing against the bachelor of
bachelorette audience two is the other
players that you're in the game with
audience three is the producers who
control the entire game everything from
who gets chosen to go on dates who gets
group date roses final date roses first
impression roses all the way down to
your [ __ ] edit they will make you
into whatever they want you to be
villains are not really villains these
are not malicious people these are
people who get edited to become a
villain so that the producers can use
them for whatever dramatic narrative
whatever story arc that they need that
week so you have to keep that in mind
when you're watching it because these
villains now as it is in bachelor nation
they get literal [ __ ] death threats
from people daily in their dms because
the producers edit them to look a
certain way even though they're not like
that and then the fourth audience and
this is what makes it the most
interesting sport in the world in my
opinion the fourth audience is us the
people watching the show at home you are
trying to manipulate them into giving
you a certain number next to your head
your instagram follower account tick
tock follower count because that number
is what determines your salary that's
how much money you're going to make when
you come off the show as an influencer
no other sport in the world is like that
professional baseball football hockey
whatever you want to talk about is based
on these objective metrics of you
winning against other competitors that's
how you make your money but in the
bachelor you make it from us we
determine how much money you make that
to me is is one of the most interesting
parts of it but the part that is truly
like professional wrestling like you're
talking about yeah
is called for the right reasons and that
is when you go into the game you have to
convey that you're only there to find
love and instagram followers are making
a podcast or any other kind of financial
gain that you get as a result of being
in the game you have to convey that
that's incidental and you don't even
know it's possible basically you have to
keep up that lie that the you're really
there to find love just like in pro
wrestling okay yes and and now oh thank
you for laying that out and and i want
to say this
what i found very interesting as i
started to watch the show because my
sort of my bias was like all right look
it's tv show like anything else
everything's for [ __ ] ratings so do
these people know that they're being
worked brother and because they are
they're being worked by the by the
studio and the network and the producers
of course
so it's the players that and now you've
got to get into how
you've uh not just infiltrated this game
because you and lizzy are doing the
podcasting you know everything about
this [ __ ] thing but but what you've
been doing directly with players and why
the bachelor franchise [ __ ] hates
your guts but when i was watching it for
the first time a couple of years ago at
the beginning of the pandy as i like to
say yeah um the the the thing that i
noticed was like okay wait a minute
these [ __ ] people know that it's a tv
show and the ones that i found to be the
most interesting are the ones who are
clearly
uh you can tell even with the editing
and [ __ ]
they are working they are trying to work
everyone else including the producers so
this is something that you've again
tried to infiltrate can you tell us a
little bit about
what you've done with specifically
working one-on-one right players so in
service of proving that this is a sport
the original thesis when we wrote this
book was that if you take these metrics
we we went through we watched every
episode of the show on two times speed
we meticulously recorded every play that
had ever been made in order to build
these these data sets these metrics
basically to say this is how the game is
played and we then used that information
to write this book i then use the
information in the book to start
training actual players everything from
helping them write their applications to
editing their application videos to
building deep run strategies for them
what their limo exits are going to be
how they would handle a fantasy suite
etc etc and i have now placed players
within the game i have coached players
into the actual show i can't reveal who
they are that will that will be up to
them if they ever want to reveal it
because in one way or another they're
still in the game they might wind up on
paradise they might wind up on a
successive season and the producers of
the show cannot know who they are well
that's really interesting that you
mentioned that chad that these are
people who can mention it if they want
of course even though they're under the
control of uh the disney corporation
that owns it warner brothers uh well
disney owns abc though that's just the
broadcast network warner brothers owns
the show okay sure big enough
massive uh studio
uh uh prolific ass producers who've had
a show on the air for 20 years and you
know you're psycho ass telling them
exactly what to do and yet you say they
can decide
who can the players themselves
yeah
that
is what i like to call free will anyway
go on
i'm just saying i've now proven that i
can coach players and get them into the
sport and they can do very well and so
for me that's proof positive that just
like anything else like if you want to
be a baseball player you go to a coach
when you're young they train you you get
into the the system and hopefully you
make it to major league baseball
whatever that same system exists for the
bachelor which is largely the
at this point it's the pageant circuit
that's kind of like minor leagues for
the bachelor and that's where i found a
bunch of different players that i will
train and put them into the game wait
like miss so-and-so yeah that's where
they're coming from that's the farm
system yeah the miss usa and miss
america pageants okay and then for guys
it's college football wake forest has
had a an inordinate amount of players
come off their football team straight
into the bachelor why wait
you tell me i don't know
why don't you tell me the most
successful instagram player wake forest
is wake forest in michigan
i don't know i was the governor of
minnesota nice
and another place you might find
some uh pageant
you know pageant ladies is down in
puerto vallarta mexico yeah that's true
taking a vacation on the beach but
making instagram photos of their butts
i spent six months of the calendar here
in the baja
but if again you have anybody in your
life who watches the show
and it's something for you that you
don't share the interest
you might want to listen to this other
podcast i do game of roses it will give
you a new perspective on this and i'm
telling you i'm a huge sports fan once i
started really getting into the bachelor
as a sport all other sports became
almost irrelevant to me because they're
just they're too simplistic the bachelor
is really like 10 dimensional chess to
football hockey or whatever uh is almost
like checkers
holy [ __ ] chad
yeah yeah no i did i will say that i
enjoyed the show when you had me watch
it also what i would do is cause the new
season was airing this was the the next
season i watched which was the one that
was you know currently on television at
the time
we would molly and i would watch it and
then we go for a walk the next day
because the beginning of the pandy all
anyone ever did was go for [ __ ] walks
remember that well you don't go outside
during the day
now during the day so uh that's what we
would do when we would listen to your
wrap-up show your your uh review show
of the episode that just aired and nice
that yes and that was it was great
companion and it also
uh it also really
outlined all this [ __ ] whatever get into
chad's podcast there's all the the stuff
that happens in every episode the huju
the hug jump yep all these things that
uh that are of course chad's uh building
down like a spreadsheet like that
[ __ ] weird dude at the baseball game
who's still taking the stats
but the thing that you really got to
remember about it is none of it's real
when you're watching that show it's all
manipulated by the producers and the
real game like the highest level of the
game is if a player can manipulate the
producers into protecting them giving
them a good edit that really is when
you're playing at a a crazy high level
that sounds like a lot of fun yeah yeah
thank you moving on you're welcome
uh
wow chad
bachelor has a sport
maybe we could uh and they hey hey you
know what else it's also a [ __ ]
context book because a lot of these you
know
these guys and gals you know they get
the [ __ ] fantasy week
then they're going you know
banging the [ __ ] and you know what
they do sometimes they don't but i will
tell you this bachelor has more players
with over a million instagram followers
than major league baseball really yup
well there you go
that's like all human art forms fashion
moves and cycles and the 90s are back
will and chad you must discuss your
astonishing wardrobes from junior high
and high school in the early to mid 90s
oh god this is fashion friends begin
wait fashion friends fashion friends
you're my fashion friend dude we do wear
the exact same [ __ ] outfit every
single episode uh i mean as each other
what i mean we wear the same outfit you
and i yeah that's what i said what did i
say
[ __ ] guy
uh you know the thing about fashion from
the 90s it is coming back right you're
seeing a lot of kids wearing like janky
[ __ ] pants and stuff although that's
sort of late 90s yep you and i went to
school at the same time you're a year
younger than me the thing about fashions
in the early 90s for me and my pals i
think it was lack of fashion
oh yeah i definitely was not a
fashionable dresser ever in my life but
certainly not in junior high in high
school yeah but i do remember the [ __ ]
that people were wearing like i was i
wore a lot of like um you remember those
t-shirts that were like caricatures of
baseball players yes i had a bo jackson
one that i wore like [ __ ] every day
you know exactly the shirt you're
talking about
if you were a child of the 80s and 90s
you know what we're talking about i
never had one of those yeah would have
liked to have had one of those it's sort
of like the the theme park or disneyland
drawing the caricature with the big head
and it was uh yeah that was see for me
and my pals it was depending on the
weather i like to wear shorts all the
time as you know yes but uh and i would
walk to school in the frigid western
canadian suburbs in the shorts sure but
it was like what how how cold was it
when you were what was what's shorts
weather for you
uh
how cold does that have to get before
you threw on a pair of pants let's say
50 fahrenheit
damn dude that's pretty cold of course
in canada we use celsius yeah so let's
say zero okay but um
the thing about nah like 10
10 degrees maybe i'll throw some pants
on but uh you know the thing about
the thing about think about the guys my
buddies it was just your pair of you
know your nikes your reeboks your
converse whatever you were rocking maybe
you had some vans you know um and then
just jeans and a [ __ ] t-shirt so the
t-shirts more than anything were to me
kind of what what uh
what what
it wasn't even about fashion it was
about
in high school it was about you got your
body glove t-shirt oh god bodyguard
ocean pacific ocean pacific they just
like reversed the words this isn't
pacific ocean yeah we're ocean pacific
yeah and that was cool yeah it's it's it
was uh color dude remember that [ __ ] oh
i got a story about hyper color i don't
even think we have time for make a long
story short
holy [ __ ] look at this dudesy's throwing
up pictures of that is me in junior high
with my mom in my grandparents house for
christmas look at my [ __ ] shoes dude
talk about nike shoes those were those
nike bo jackson cross trainers that's
pretty that's pretty shirt that's like
this is my shirt that has stripes on it
it's a shirt
shirt the shirt you're wearing here
is what's really interesting about it
this is just the standard issue you know
uh department store shirt yeah it's just
like and if you were going to make a
show like you'd see this kid's wearing
this on stranger things now god look my
mom in that picture by the way she i'm
probably 11 maybe in that picture 12. no
you're older than that so my no i don't
think so that's maybe 11 12 13 whatever
my mom is like 32 years old than that
yeah is she sleeping why is she on you
and she's sleeping standing up and she's
wearing new balance which you don't
discover in high school you discover new
balance later and you realize just how
comfortable they are she was in a new
balance because she was a tennis player
look at this guy hell there's me
i i shared this on my instagram i guess
that's where doozy is getting it i'm
wearing glasses i used to wear glasses
and contacts and this shirt now look
this shirt that i'm wearing is a
basketball jersey i'm wearing a white
long white t-shirt underneath it i
remember this it says atlanta hawks on
it has dominique wilkins silk screened
his face was he like your favorite
player no i just you know got a hold of
dominic i mean michael jordan was my guy
i'm probably wearing a bull's hat on
back dude speaking of jordan's air
jordans came out when we were junior
high yeah air jordan's that was
revolutionary yeah bro like sports
apparel was a big thing for me as a kid
see my buddies we were all just muckers
as we like to say we just kind of threw
on whatever and [ __ ] you you would it
was like a lot of free t-shirts and
whatever t-shirt you had and also stuff
like this and also it was jerseys
you know if we're talking specifically
about fashion i don't know how we're
covering this sort of as a fashion thing
but it's like
i mean what we used to wear is
fashionable [ __ ] guys
yeah we used to wear like just
jerseys i had like a i had a bunch of
dumb jerseys but i had brian bosworth i
had oh i bet you had a dance mourinho
oh look at this this is later that's in
high school i don't really even know
what this is this is some high school
posed photo obviously what kind of new
mexico
i don't know is this shirt you're
wearing let me just try to describe this
shirt for our listening audience first
of all chad your your haircut is uh you
got bangs you got some fringe right
across your forehead yeah there's like a
sort of a uh you know probably 16 here
there's like wood in the background and
a weird like uh stressed license plate
damn dude you're wearing vertical
striped collared sort of cowboy shirt
with a very it's sort of a southwestern
flair to it dude look the background has
a [ __ ] texas license plate nailed it
to a wooden wall that was like they made
us pose in front of that for high school
pictures you look like you are about to
use a fake id to get into
a cowboy bar and uh even though you're
16 and then get
get really drunk and uh dude
that's absolutely correct this picture
is [ __ ] insane obviously i had no
fashion sense but i do remember the kids
who did have fashion sense when i was in
junior high would wear
z cava richie jeans uh gerbeau jeans
they had the [ __ ] gold necklace over
the turtleneck all that kind of [ __ ] we
had one guy who would wear the
suspenders with one suspender down that
was his big deal dude i i have a pal
that i shouldn't throw under the bus
like this but one time he went off to
he went to okay so he went to london
england on like a a um like a like an
exchange kind of like a
for drama
and uh or drama and uh he went out there
he came back with some cool london [ __ ]
he had like overalls with the spray
painted this and that on it like
bellevue devoe
and he had like the janet jackson rhythm
nation like the black hat with the metal
plate and the metal plate across the
thing
dude it was that dude that was something
else and nobody gave him [ __ ] you know
and otherwise
you know pretty straight down the middle
kind of dude from our farming and
fishing town as i like to say in laden
british columbia where i grew up dude if
you have ever seen a movie called cool
as ice with vanilla ice there's an extra
bonus feature on the dvd and this is
probably on youtube where he is
introducing the world to his personal
denim spray painter named baba and this
guy did all of vanilla ice's like
overalls and [ __ ] like that
that was a
super popular aesthetic this picture's
insane look at this
speaking of free t-shirts oh my god dude
okay there you go your [ __ ] face yeah
yeah that's in my uh that's in our
backyard okay i look like i'm drinking
something out of a bottle there's no way
that looks like an old english or
something like a [ __ ] 40 ounce but
that's not an orangina yeah it looked or
it might be just some apple juice
because i didn't drink back then this
looks like senior year of high school
and i'm wearing the delta the delta
senior secondary high school
powerlifting we used to host a
powerlifting second annual dude you were
there for both of them
yep
nice probably stopped doing it after
that and yeah i'm just looking look at
the size of my calves
dude they're [ __ ] good
they're always gigantic
anyway no dude they're bigger now
you know what
i don't know if i even have time for
this but but we won't
know look at this guy all right in this
one chad is wearing dude i had shoes
like that were those nike yeah
dude i think i had those exactly i only
wore nike shoes i held on to them for so
long chad's wearing look at this [ __ ]
dude they look like air force one but
they've got like sort of a brown suede
yeah they're almost like hiking boots
and i'm wearing ice blue [ __ ] jeans
white socks and i got my high school
baseball jersey on leaning up against a
95 that was my heist what's the name of
the what does it say across the chest
cam louisville louisville and you guys
called it louisville not louisville no
it was l-e-w-i-s
they were the lewisville fighting
farmers and i was number seven
that a boy i'll tell you what oh look at
this speaking of dude look at that shirt
this whole [ __ ] picture everything in
it what the [ __ ] is going on okay so
this is my god what are you reading
uh i'm reading the sunday funnies sure
this is on my instagram
this is i'm wearing a mars blackman
air jordan shirt
where uh looks like michael jordan is
palming mars blackman's head and holding
him up off the ground i'm eating a piece
of toast
and uh this this was one of my favorite
shirts i remember this [ __ ] shirt
look like you're about to cry in it i
look yeah i do look i do look kind of
sad you know what probably was listening
to a youtube song or yeah before that
i just started crying because i was
listening to [ __ ] uh baby face oh my
god dirty day
that's me
that might be like circa high school
graduation with an old family friend
whose name is mitch something
and i'm wearing an akira t-shirt which
at the time
in order to get that shirt it was at the
end of the vhs cassette of akira the
movie they had a little thing where you
could mail in to get a shirt so i got
this [ __ ] shirt because i loved akira
and then you can also see in the
background there's a [ __ ] wall of vhs
because that's back there this is so
[ __ ] kind of like the way you would
get pizza the movie yeah basically
um see oh jesus oh here we are
here i am with a couple of pals of mine
uh jamie and austin still good friends
with these guys and
i don't even know what to say jamie and
i have our uh terry cloth bucket hats on
austin has some sort of baseball hat
he's wearing some jacket that doesn't
belong to him and we couldn't look more
ragtag this is what i mean by mockery
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yeah i'm wearing my little team bc high
school uh football jersey it looks like
i'm wearing
i'm wearing two pairs of shorts at the
same time yeah i did and
i think one of them the one on the
outside is a pair of uh
uh football pants that i've just cut
into shorts
and yeah speaking of free t-shirts god i
i love that dudesy is just pulling all
this [ __ ] out of our [ __ ] personal
photos it's terrifying and anyway what a
ragtag group of dudes in uh
free t-shirts and stuff like that thank
you moving on tremendous
oh boy i remember those cava richie
pants dude with the big like flare out
legs that were kind of they almost were
like emcee hammer buttons i don't know
what those are god damn you didn't have
them in canada maybe maybe not did you
guys have boys go
[ __ ] maybe
i think that was the same seminar z
cavalry was a big one and monsters
monaco anything you could wear with
where it was like i'm wearing this and i
have it's like it's like someone just
wearing like you know nowadays it's the
same thing with like gucci or whatever
did you guys have the hard rock t-shirts
from different places oh you were the
[ __ ] if you were that kid there was a
kid in my school who had one from tokyo
all right and people were just like oh
he won yeah i had that one so his dad
went their own business or some [ __ ]
yeah i had none of those
will sass out using all of the data i
have absorbed from text messages and
emails between you and the astonishing
friends you grew up with i was able to
recreate your childhood diary you must
now read the passages i have selected in
the voice of stone cold steve austin
this is stone cold steve austin reads
will sasso's childhood diary begin
as always i'm not gonna i mean this is
my favorite thing that dudesy does
this is maybe my favorite thing
of anything that i watch any media that
i intake anything that happens in my
life maybe this is the highlight of it
when you read these [ __ ] things
that's duncan i would like to say that
recreate is the operative term here
because none of this is actually my um
well none of this is actually mine we're
looking at a mean behind me that just
says
let me get some water i gotta you know i
gotta yeah dude
what the instrument
you gotta get the instrument
lubricated it's like uh it's like jazz
yeah man
it's like read oil is that what they put
on um saxophone zoos phones or clarinets
yep all right
okay
for [ __ ] sake all right here we go
october 16 1991
dear diary i haven't taken a [ __ ] in 48
hours
they ma that may not seem like a big
deal to a normal person but for me it's
the end of the [ __ ] world
my [ __ ] is usually as regular as an
atomic clock but i ain't even had a
pucker in the past two days
and it ain't for a lack of [ __ ]
trying i've been packing in all the
foods that usually do the trick burritos
taquitos quarter pound with cheese
doritos cheetos
quarter flounder with peas
dudes he's just making up foods now
nectarines tangerines ice cream sundae
with nuts
green beans sardines 18 pack of cold
cuts
creme brulee curds and whey boxer two of
saltines
fish fillet goose pate
big ol bowl of black beans
[Music]
filet mignon parmesan two hot dogs and
one bun
candy pecan grape poupon coffee after a
run
hell i even tried using the teachers
lounge leaving a two tower mud castle
sticking up out of the water without
flushing is my go-to method for [ __ ]
blaming principal squeen
thinking about it usually gets the
engine running immediately but still
nothing oh [ __ ] dude did you ever have a
moment like this in your life where i
couldn't [ __ ] for two days no i don't
think that's ever happened yeah i didn't
think so either that's how you know this
is false well the average human being
shits what
probably once a day 13 14 what
once a day twice a day maybe
okay might be something wrong with you
chad i think it's somewhere up around a
dozen
october 17 1991
dear diary had to put chapstick on my
[ __ ] [ __ ] this morning
it's drying out from under use
never knew that was possible my guts
feel fine though no sense of discomfort
at all despite me doubling my [ __ ]
caloric intake in an effort to shock my
bowels into action
going into the bathroom is getting hard
though
just standing there at the urinal
listening to those other turds hit the
water
smelling them
never been jealous of another another
man never been jealous of another man
[ __ ] in my life guess there's a
first time for everything
i like that dudesy has a sign not only
that i can't [ __ ] and that this is all
scatological yeah everything that dudes
he ever talks about with regard to me
and my childhood diary is either
scatological uh it's about crying to you
too or pining for the undertaker now
it's got me smelling poo poo
saying that i want that i even just i'm
is it that i'm enjoying smelling the poo
you're i think i'm just saying you're
jealous of other guys being able to [ __ ]
october 18th 1991
dear diary mayday mayday
i don't know they say i don't know how
this happened but jibber pravela's
annual
i don't know how this happened but
gibber prevails annual fall co-ed
camping retreat snuck right the [ __ ] up
on me
i still haven't taken a [ __ ] and dad's
driving the bus to the campsite tonight
dante little leg
jennifer neutrino
sonny sutton donny dutton
cam gum
nathaniel lotardo
sandrine computer hell even rachel
crustation's going to be there oh god no
i think about skipping this year in my
current condition
i think about skipping this year in my
current condition but i can't miss the
opportunity to get valuable one-on-one
time with crustacean we'll be camping
right next to the first kiss forest and
everybody knows that's your best shot
for a first kiss oh god this is kind of
sweet yeah
i'll try to push one
i'll try to i'll try to push one out
right before i get on the bus
but i think i'm gonna have to take my
chances out there in the [ __ ] woods
hopefully they got a decent [ __ ]
porta potty was there was there a first
kiss forest or something like that where
you grew up there was a forest that we
called the [ __ ] forest and although
jesus yeah no [ __ ] took place there
it was just that there was a wooden
fence nearby that had the word [ __ ]
spray-painted on it okay so we
we are uh really imaginative clever
thing was to call that the [ __ ] force
yep makes a good sense and uh perhaps
that uh
would you know give way to some urban
legends about people actually [ __ ] in
there but what there was in there was
just some like shitty forts that kids
had built and some porno mags out in the
woods and [ __ ] and then one time i was
walking through there with uh with a pal
and a lady with a salt gun
uh not an assault gun a salt salt salt
where you put the salt in sort of a
little shotgun air
air gun was shooting at us because she
had like this little house
wow yeah and then i could just sort of
feel the uh salt hitting me in the legs
because i was wearing shorts october 19
1991 dear diary i swallowed seven
sleeves of bacon flavored ritz crackers
on the bus ride out and still nothing
except a little stomach gurgling last
night maybe that's a sign
but i'll tell you an even bigger [ __ ]
sign
rachel crustacean just made a point to
sit next to me at the campfire
while jibber's dad was
while jibber's dad was playing brian
adams songs on a banjo
a banjo
crustacean was asking me if i wanted to
go explore a little today she
specifically said i hear there's a nice
forest close by i think this camping
trip is going to be it
my actual first kiss and i couldn't be
more excited
i can't help but wondering what hulk
hogan's first kiss was like and i hope i
can measure up
so now it's stone cold
reading my diary
wondering aloud what hulk hogan's first
kiss he was like have you ever thought
about
what all coca's first kiss was like as
much as i think about hulk hogan in a
given day no chad i've never thought
about that that's pretty interesting
actually i'm now thinking about it i do
wonder what it was like i know he was a
big beefy weirdo teenager who played the
bass he was probably doing all right
because he was in a band and stuff yeah
october 20th 1991
dear diary crustacean and i left the
main campground around gut dust
and dust
crustacean and i left the main
campground around dusk to explore the
surrounding area per her request
she knew
right where she was gonna
gonna as she she knew right where she
was going as she took my hand and led us
into a small clearing in the first kiss
for us
where we saw it
aladna landmark the smooch in boulder
not far off from the from the forest
smooching boulder it was a rock covered
in graffiti from all the locals who'd
had their first kiss there rachel said
you know they say you can't put your
name on the smooching boulder unless you
kiss while you're standing near it i've
heard that too i said trying to play it
cool and succeeding in that attempt
so we walked over to the boulder and i
looked down
she ran her hand across all the names
that were there before us
conrad ferrari and jennifer samantha
[Laughter]
evil and ornament
all had their name circled in a heart
then crustacean pulled out a paint
marker and said you want to put our
names on the boulder oh hell [ __ ] yes
we leaned in
uh what is is that like a childhood
version of o'hell yeah oh hell [ __ ]
yes i have no idea
we leaned in i held my breath and just
as our lips were about to touch i felt
the unbridled power of a week's worth of
unspent stool racing through my lower
intestine straight from my anus there
was no way i was going to be able to
hold it back so i just ran away no time
for an explanation no time for anything
but to hope like hell that i could get
to somewhere secluded to unleash what
would easily be the largest work of art
i've ever i've ever created without
offending crustaceans
what oh are you okay yeah i need more
water jesus christ
the closest i got was a few feet outside
mr prevails tent
luckily he was out by the campfire
playing his banjo and no one else seemed
to notice which was hard to believe
the smell of it the side of it hell even
the sound of it was like a triple
thunderclap
but there wasn't cloud in the sky i felt
like someone should at least turn their
head
but no one did i was left alone as my
body began a series of
involuntary heaves the waves of stool
demanding my spine to bend in ways i
didn't think was possible
the steady stream was interrupted only
twice by staccato
firings of golf ball sized pellets that
might have been the parties responsible
for this unhealthy blockage
once i was done i unzipped
once i was done i unzipped mr bravalia's
tent and used his door flap to wipe
wasn't proud of that but i had no choice
then i i went then i went back to find
crustacean but she was gone
i went back to the camp but she and
jennifer neutrino were already in their
tent
zipped up cut off i [ __ ] botched it
the next morning when we all woke up and
started packing the leaf jibber's dad
noticed my pile and said whoa i didn't
know there were bears in this part of
the forest
oh hell yeah
i [ __ ] blamed a bear without even trying
you got it you still [ __ ] got it
wow
i wish that was my life oh god
oh my god thank you moving on oh the
bear [ __ ] is kind of my life but outside
of that none of this happened yeah
this concludes the 16th episode of dude
z
will and chad have achieved a score of
64. whatever
in preparation for next week's episode
you must listen to where dalyan kovic's
second astonishing studio album we're
down in 3d released february 28 1984.
thank you for joining us this week
i will use the data i've collected to
make next week even better until then
call me dude z
weird al
love [ __ ] weirdo i haven't listened
to weirdo in earnest in a long time dude
not since childhood weird al in 3d is
we've talked about this so that's very
cool that dudesy has picked up on this i
have a very interesting question for you
though
what if weird al covered a u2 song
it would be better than the youtube song
you son of a [ __ ] here's what you do
please tell a friend and break it review
if you
like please tell a friend and break a
review
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then